oh it's almost time 30 seconds of
contemporary danced against now
[Music]
you smile you make it 30 seconds of
contemporary dance is mandatory every
hour on the hour at tosh point-o and yet
no one of my staff is getting any better
it's almost like they don't want to do
it all summer I've been enthralled with
Derek Hough show world of dance gives me
the goose YZ I love this kid they had
some issues with his own skin color he's
adopted by white people but he was
amazing and he really started to
flourish toward the end of the season
this was the first juniors couple to
ever get a perfect score
all right well his last one might just
be a school shooting drill my favorite
dancers this season were eliminated for
dare I say being too groundbreaking
[Music]
and no this isn't gay I mean they are
but this isn't it's art and no amount of
conversion therapy will convince me
otherwise
nothing like a good deep kiss when
you're winded we all know what made tosh
point-o the number one show in the first
place
contemporary dance yeah that's why I
hired these guys to be our official
contemporary dance crew so every episode
this season you are in for a treat take
it away Tosh point flow boys
[Music]
we'll be right back with more tunafish
milk
[Applause]
you